breaking overnight the olympics host
city of tokyo reported its highest
ever daily number of new coronavirus
cases
the confirmed total of more than 2 800
new cases surpasses
a previous record set back in january
japan's prime minister is
out with new advice for sports fans who
have been gathering to watch the games
lucy kraft is in tokyo
the city of tokyo has asked hospitals to
add hundreds of beds
and postpone surgeries and other
non-coveted treatments
to meet the surge in covet cases only
about a quarter of japan's population
is fully vaccinated prime minister suga
is urging citizens to stay home
and avoid unnecessary trips but as you
can see behind me there's a crowd of
people lined up just to take their
pictures at the olympic rings
so that message about staying home may
not resonate with many citizens
the prime minister has insisted however
that the surge in cases
is not a problem for the games doctors
of course
say the games are partly to blame for
the surge
for cbs this morning lucy craft tokyo